thank you David for biting me thank you
everyone for coming I think the panel is
also for the wonderful words they just
gave us today thank you it's for me
today I decided to tell you my story of
you know as a survivor as a survivor who
went through the genocide so I will
share with you some of my experiences of
what happened to me but it's not always
easy for a survivor to recall or
describe the things you went through
during that time it is painful but I
feel like it's my obligation to tell the
story of my family and also to let
others keep learning from what we went
through as a person who see alive and
also to to honor the memories of our
loved ones who were killed simply being
suited and and I think that's what I
will keep doing for the rest of my life
I'm here and I think that in the
meantime I do that also it helps me in
my healing as well because the genocide
has really done a lot of damages to me
but I think that I mean I mean in a good
way now these days you know I'm strong
enough I'm very um couragous to be able
to tell my story in 1994 of the same age
as event I was 14 years old and I was
living and smoked out like this woman
they just showed on a clip in western
province I i had my both parents who
were teachers in the community they were
serving the community like everybody
else and and I had four siblings my
younger sister was second and then my
three younger brothers who were they
and then youngest was almost 18 months
old in during the genocide before the
genocide was just a happy family like
everybody else and but other time in a
community where he lived you know at a
young age for me I didn't know much
about what was happening but for me to
hear that as 2 t's were discriminated in
a community in in the society in Iran de
it was the hurtful thing for me to see
that my father who was serving as a
teacher teaching everyone not
discriminating anyone but all of a
sudden he's being discriminated against
just simply being a Tutsi it's really
sad it's really hurtful and we were
false like many others in airport to go
into hiding and I remember this first
place we went into hiding in you know
during that time we had to figure out
every place that you go to hide in the
first place you went to hide it was a
friend of us because we had to go you
know I remember in our area in the
community area there were so many people
actually who were going to the stadium
and when we were going to the stadium on
our way they are following the crowd
because my mom's instincts came through
her she said no you don't have to follow
the crowd and remembering actually the
people were going to the stadium cousin
Rhonda majority are Christians so were
just people were just singing gospel
songs and I have one of them that stuck
in my head when the people were just
saying Jesus happens through these
trials and tribulations who are going
through and it was very hard for me to
see all people women and kids leaving
their homes and looking every Hill the
house being burned down and destroyed in
but and then terrified hearing on the
radio everywhere that we have to be
killed it was the hardest thing for me I
couldn't describe the Fiat within
and how I felt it was very very hard and
I remember on our way there when my mom
is digs came through her that we
supposed to go to a friend and go hide
in there and looking on outside I saw
the killer's they were carrying machetes
they had this huge big wooden thick with
nails on top actually used to call them
come on Connor in Kinyarwanda which
means not pity for our enemies and
seeing that I recalled seeing someone in
my neighborhood actually who used to
make them every time I used to go to
school and I used to wonder what what is
this have four and as a kid I was very
curious asked my dad but he didn't know
himself is he I don't know and
remembering that I just recalled it and
sauce everybody carrying that so during
that time the man was making them every
day I go to school they were finished
and everyone was buying that and III
kept when I saw that I remember to say
well that they made it to for them to
kill us and when you went there to that
friend of my parents he too they took
they took us in the ceiling and there
was no other place it could keep us and
when we were there I remember hearing
people outside how they have to
exterminate the 2 t's you know from
young to old it was very defined for me
to hear how people have been so you know
bad to that to that level of hating
people that they have to exterminate
them and being there in the ceiling you
know the young KD was very high you know
for hard for me but at the same time
also thinking maybe we will get a chance
to go back home but that was not the
kids and in those times people really
have changed completely and sometimes
you didn't know who to go to and I
remember well in where they are these
people this
I not to keep us anymore and the I
remember that early in the morning it
was around 5am and when we left at the
hormone they told us you have to leave
and go find the other place to hide and
when we were in the bushes was around
the SOG on plantation around the river
and I heard this crowd of people you
know around and cutting the bushes and
saying you know what you know we're
going to kill you so badly show
yourselves now come out cockroaches and
all that they you know they had all
these in names they were calling us and
my dad was really really I could see he
was chained know the kitty always want
to see your daddy really strong another
moment he wasn't so and my aunt maternal
aunt was without at a time because the
resolve the other family members were in
different places and and my mom just
looked all of us and say you know keep
praying that's the only word she could
tell us in and we would what we did we
just pray with you no heart so and when
we came out of the bushes my aunt was
kind of scared and when she turned
around on the other side they killed her
so later on my siblings told me that
they saw what happened how they killed
her but we didn't see that because we
just saw was moving and I remember that
how the people looked they were very
very terrifying actually the way wearing
banana leaves around their waist and
carrying machetes and and those big you
know I wouldn't think in your head and
it was very very hard for me to observe
how people have have really really
changing and they are all around looking
the other human beings to kill them and
and i remember at a time it was during
the day and we had to go to figure out
some other place to hide and that
incident it was very terrifying even
though they didn't you know killed but
they killed my aunt but we were thinking
that probably we got to be killed some
other place and we had a really really
difficult
circumstances and another place I
remember we kept going and when my dad
was followed and when we were hiding in
the ceiling and to that place one of the
hardest thing for me to hear being in
the ceiling is to hear that how people
were so happy that they have murder
people and they were roaring themselves
and I remember when we were sitting in
the ceiling these killers came down and
they were walking around and saying how
many people they have murdered I
couldn't believe you know saying that
they were happy that they have murdered
my dad whom they have been following
after they found us and he was as a kid
as you can imagine hearing that your dad
is killed simply being who you know just
the truth is was the hardest thing for
me to hear and i remember it was myself
and my mom we came comforting each other
you know and the rest of my siblings
were you know yeah of course they didn't
hear that but we kept comforting each
other that so anything you could do but
we're waiting for our turn so and I
remember another place at a time where
we went to hide and to show you how
people have changed but some other
people were also good and I remember
this place my mom was trying to take us
to whatever she can take us we're going
through the bushes it was rainy and I
remember this place we went and my mom
knocked the door was during the night
and when she not the door to that woman
house actually she was part of the
kidding her husband was at the roadblock
killing people during the night so and
when we knock the door and we kept
begging the woman refused to open the
door and I remember the kids inside
screaming and begging her please mom can
you help Oh our teacher actually my mom
used to teach those kids that's why they
were begging they
mom to open for us and another moment I
really was touched by how kind these
kids have been and apparent was really
unkind but because of the you know the
parent begging for for their mom so they
allowed us to go in the house but we
were so thankful and it was in those
times we have been like going through
the bushes and we're so hungry with the
need for a long time and it was really
really painful and I remember another
place because we went to several places
and in this particular place when we
found you know by killers my mom was
taken by those killers um actually there
was thinking that she can offer
something so that they can leave us even
though that's what they were saying but
it was just just to kind of like keep
taking her to places whenever they want
it can kill her whenever they want to
and the rest of us they left us where we
were and they took her with my younger
brother cuz she was carrying my younger
brother the whole time because was very
young and um when I was hearing this mom
I'm talking about her kids and my mom
was you know like the same like her
carry her own kids and not knowing what
to do and and I remember when we were
there we didn't know what to do so we
didn't know without mom would survive
and let around when we kept searching
actually later on the men who was hiding
us refused to keep as any longer he said
no I have to go and find your mom so we
were able to find a hurt so we managed
to be able to find her so we got to a
place where the left to her you know
waiting whenever time they wanted they
will kill her actually throughout that
did have been taking her to several you
know places everybody you know thinking
when they are going to kill her when
ever you know it was it was it was very
very bad and when we got there these
killers have already seen that to my
brothers were still alive and in those
times to see a man even a little boy I
see alive it was almost like they have
never done anything and they said we are
going to kill the boys and then you you
know the rest of the girls we're going
to do whatever you know let around
whenever we want to and i remember at a
time when they came to where we were the
man who came actually with the killers
to kill my brothers was somebody who
grew up with my mom my grandfather has
offered a land where they lived actually
his parents lived for those for those
years that means there were very very
good friends for many many years and he
came you know with the killers which was
very even I imagine someone like him
coming and say he's going to do that and
I remember they can see this mom here my
mom was it was very very painful for her
she was begging for all of us to be
taken be killed and all of us were
begging to be taken be killed over at
the same time but these killers have
decided what they wanted to do yeah and
they wanted to kill my brothers first
and I remember when we begged them and
defused and um they snatch my brothers
and took them to our burn house in and
came back talking how they have killed
him I kill them it was the hardest thing
for me and my mom to deal with in my
sister we kind of lost it and and you're
not begging to be killed in those times
when you see something and that happens
you don't want to be alive anymore
because you don't know what they're
going to do to you and
the only thing we could do we just keep
you know being strong and be able to
keep hiding it we didn't know whether
we're going to survive and I remember
this place also we went to hide in this
particular place and this man was part
of the killing and and the woman was
kind but sometimes you find somebody in
the house was a kind and the other
person was horrible terrible and when
you were there this man came back in the
house with with the killer actually who
was having us word carrying this world
and who looks like he has murdered many
many people everywhere and he looked
even up to this time I could see the
image of how he looked like it's it's
like a picture in my head I remember
somehow I don't know one way through his
mind he snatched me from everyone and as
you know during the genocide who raped
was used as a weapon to women in the
country most of the women a lot of women
survivors have been raped in some of
them live with HIV others live with the
disabilities you know from at a time
some of them have been murdered and
right away and he's you know us he
snatched me from everyone and everyone
you know kept begging if you want to
kill all of us kill all of us right away
on the spot and he refused and the men
who was they actually didn't even stop
him to do that and I remember when we he
just you know drugged me on the street
and be me with this word around my body
else bleeding around and bruising and of
course I was screaming a lot and
unfortunately without going into details
where he took me and all that so I was
raped by him like what happened to many
other women he was you know I I didn't
want to leave any more after that
happened to me the only thing I was
waiting for anybody to kill me on the
street while I was walking on the street
and when you you survive something
happen in you know you don't know what's
going to happen and I was managed myself
to go about to wear my mom was in and
she took care of my injuries and the
woman there so it was the hardest thing
as a mom to see and losing her beloved
kitten seeing her daughter what happened
to her it was the hardest some pain she
can have within herself more than
actually me we kept hiding and
fortunately a good kind of hearted
person in the most of my community where
we actually not far from where we we
grew up and they here is until the
country was repeatedly by the RPF end
and then right after the genocide with
everything he went through and finding
out many of your family members are
being murdered and you are and
everything that happened to you I was I
thought they crushed in my soul my
spirit and my emotionally
psychologically I didn't even know that
I would be a very function person being
able to do anything in my life anymore
but thankfully that gradually that with
the help of also my mom who has been
very strong and supportive but I am so
fortunate because not so many who have
parents like if it doesn't have parents
so at least I've been nearby her
throughout the whole time to encourage
me to leave
be strong and and that helped me so much
and not being able not be carry any
anger or hatred towards the people have
done unto me and that helped a lot and
after also going through the trials in
within and in the pain later on I found
that I contracted HIV as a result of
rape and I was also another difficult
thing to live with but I had to keep
striving to live and and as you know not
everybody has the same strength to leave
and cause some survivors still now see
carry that pain within themselves and
couldn't be able to describe the ax
painful memories in but I think that for
me i feel that i needed to also keep you
know talking what happened to even those
who cannot talk about their stories so
at least they can hear themselves in my
story as i described it and he was a
throughout the journey for me I lived I
kept reminding myself that I should not
give up on hope and hope one of the
mantra that I created that I live with
on it every day in my life is that no
matter what circumstances you may face
in your life you never never lose hope
for losing hope is the beginning of your
own self defeat another thing is I keep
reminding myself is one of the code from
Nelson Mandela when I said resentment is
like drinking poison and hoping that it
will kill somebody else and that reminds
me also to keep do the right thing and
keep being able to leave well so that I
can help my community contributing to my
convey to the healing of our our
community thank you very much